things are better the world is better
just because there's not a war does it
mean there's peace he's coming some call
him apocalypse he was some kind of God
for thousands of years he's been
amassing mutants to take their powers he
always had four followers like the Four
Horsemen Eric don't join them whatever
it is you think you saw me I buried it
with my family together we will cleanse
the earth everything they've built will
fall and from the ashes of their world
will build a better one like never felt
power like this before they took him
present the world needs the x-men I'm
not here students we've got to you if
i'm going to teach your kids something
i'm going to teach them how to fight
follow me uh-huh I'm not afraid of him I
need oh he's my father what I me my mom
yeah I know
not all of us can control our powers
then don't
apocalypse means to destroy this world
it's all of us against a god and the
most powerful beings on earth
forget everything you think you know
none of that
you're not students anymore I'll take
care of anything from that your ex
well you've been busy we had a little
help